all right we got to talk about that
season one finale okay it's a bit of a
shocker
what was your reaction well when reading
the script I was like that is a hell of
a cliffhanger to leave that we do for
sure address some things in season two I
can't give too much away but I'm just
really excited for fans to see what
we've been cooking up because we've been
out here in Toronto filming we're about
halfway done yeah it's crazy I want to
know what the fan reaction was when we
saw what happened to Haley Joel Osment
getting up close and personal with that
bathroom sink the fan reaction I mean
it's just brutal he did not have to slam
his head that many times but he did just
like the nicest dude he didn't deserve
that in any way so I think my reaction
was just like wow summarize it in a
noise in a face so this is really
exciting with season two the fan
reaction has been so strong critics are
loving the show is there anything you
can tease us in terms of characters
coming up or guest appearances okay okay
well this is this has been out there we
have the amazing iya cash coming in
season two she plays a little superhero
named storm front and she shakes things
up in a very interesting way so that's
gonna be really exciting and all I can
promise it's gonna be bigger it's gonna
go deeper with all the characters it
might get bloodier yeah I can't say too
much but I'm so so freaking promising is
there any way that we can get either one
of your parents as guest stars maybe
like Supes villains oh man you'd have to
ask them I don't know it might be too
violent for them I saw your dad the
intruder he was amazing he was he was I
don't know maybe maybe one day who knows
we need to cook this up okay we have a
calendar I want to show you rope I have
this in my apartment oh yeah no no they
were giving this out of Comic Con and I
it's in my apartment in LA right now yes
that's amazing so what's your birthday
we got to see what say
if up at the pan flash through this oh
my gosh any dip there we go oh my god he
gives a good face I have a gloomy month
in the Jeep calendar I don't love that
about myself maybe we can change your
birthday legit yeah sure sure yeah I
personally would probably wants yeah I
probably want an October birthday cause
you're the pumpkin who's celebrating
Halloween on the beach right that's not
happening this guy